Вітаю глядачів відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину"!
У своїх коментарях ви пропонували показати, як полюють і рибалять у ФРН.
Земля Північний-Рейн Вестфалія - ідеальне місце для обох цих видів дозвілля.
Ви лише подивіться, яка краса!
У цій серії пропоную розібратися, як німцям вдалося
досягнути балансу між збереженням стародавніх промислів і захистом довкілля.
Я їду у передмістя Дюссельдорфа за 70 кілометрів від Бонна,
аби зустрітися з очільником місцевого єгерства.
Його рекомендували  як досвідченого професіонала.
Ну що ж, ось я і в містечку Губельрат.
Ходімо познайомимось зі справжнім мисливцем.
Це родинний маєток нашого героя. Будівлі 200 років.
Вона переходить від батька до сина з 18 століття.
Оригінальна цегляна огорожа маєтку збереглася до сьогодні.
Колесо від воза, дрова - час тут наче зупинився.
Господар Ґерд Шпікер показує своїх двох овець.
Каже, вони у нього замість газонокосарки.
А десяток курей гарантують свіжі яйця щодня.
Завжди кажуть: мисливцям дозволено полювати, все відстрілювати.
Однак про те, що мисливець водночас зобов'язаний доглядати за тваринами,
у важкі часи підгодовувати їх, захищати від хвороб - про це часто забувають.
Господар запрошує у дім.
Саме так я і уявляв класичне помешкання німецького єгеря.
Старовинні різьблені меблі,
настінний годинник з маятником,
крісла біля каміна для оповідок про полювання.
Ну що ж, друзі, я в гостях у справжнього мисливця.
Ґерд Шпікер займається мисливством 60 років. Подивіться на його трофеї.
Вперше батько взяв Ґерда на полювання у віці 12 років.
У 16 років він отримав своє мисливське посвідчення.
Для цього треба пройти кількамісячні курси і скласти три іспити.
Це стрільба по рухомих мішенях, а також письмова та усна оцінка знань
з біології диких тварин, мисливських видів тварин,
гігієни, методів полювання, дресирування мисливських собак
та мисливського права.
До 18 років можна полювати лише у супроводі дорослих.
Посвідчення мисливця діє три роки, після цього його треба продовжувати.
При цьому перевіряють, чи не став я терористом, чи не був оштрафований.
Мисливство в РН - захоплення не з дешевих.
За навчання на курсах треба викласти від однієї до трьох тисяч євро,
залежно від регіону. За іспит додатково ще до 300 євро.
Річний членський внесок до мисливської спілки коливається від 50 до 150 євро.
Мисливське посвідчення дає право отримати дозвіл на володіння зброєю.
Умови видачі: повноліття, відсутність залежностей, судимостей,
добрий зір та страховка особистої відповідальності.
Навички володіння зброєю перевіряють на іспиті.
Мисливське посвідчення разом із дозволом на володіння зброєю
дає право придбати довгоствол: рушницю та гвинтівку,
і  короткоствол: пістолет та револьвер.
Також із собою на полюванні треба мати картку власника зброї.
Ось таку. У неї внесена моя зброя -
двоствольна рушниця з вертикальним розташуванням стволів
та гвинтівка з магазином.
Ґерд Шпікер веде до святая святих: сейфу зі зброєю.
Ключі від нього лежать у ще одному сейфі з кодом.
А тепер відверніться.
А, точно!
Для володіння зброєю потрібно мати спеціальний сейф,
дозволений для зберігання відповідного типу і кількості зброї.
Мисливець має право передавати зброю на тимчасове користування
та зберігання іншому мисливцеві.
Напівавтоматична і автоматична зброя  заборонена.
Ґерд Шпікер демонструє свою гладкоствольну рушницю
і набої з дробом, з якими ходить на зайця.
А це вже набій для нарізної гвинтівки.
Далі дістає нарізний карабін Маузер з оптичним прицілом.
Це для косуль, диких кабанів, оленів, так званої червоної дичини.
для тих, кого ми ще називаємо парнокопитними.
Ви лише подивіться, яке могутнє дерево
росте на подвір'ї пана Шпікера. Цьому буку 140 років.
Під родинним буком дід вчить ходити своїх онуків.
Свого часу й він робив тут свої перші кроки.
Усі діти Ґерда Шпікера - двоє синів і донька, - мисливці.
Серед німецьких мисливців невпинно зростає  частка жінок.
На сьогодні їх приблизно 10%, а серед учнів курсів вже 25% -
такі дані  Німецької асоціації мисливців.
Їдемо на угіддя, де полює Ґерд Шпікер.
У ФРН спільноти мисливців не мають власних угідь.
Ділянку для полювання треба орендувати у землевласника.
Кількість і вид дичини, яку можна вполювати,
визначається "планом відстрілу", який мисливець узгоджує з власником угідь.
Для кожної ділянки існують науково обґрунтовані норми видобутку дичини.
Федеральний закон про полювання зобов'язує вести його так,
щоб в країні зберігалися стійка кількість і різноманіття популяцій диких тварин.
Залежно від зміни чисельності тих чи інших видів у федеральних землях
постійно змінюється список тварин, на яких дозволено полювати.
Сьогодні зранку мені телефонували з поліції і повідомили,
що неподалік звідси на автотрасі збили косулю і її треба прибрати.
І це, на жаль, теж наш обов'язок:
після нещасних випадків забирати загиблу дичину з дороги.
А на різні випадки під час полювання у пана Шпікера повна сумка важливих речей.
Для екстреної допомоги - перев'язувальні матеріали.
Мотузка, аби витягти добуту дичину.
Ніж для патрання тварини.
Дощовик.
Ліхтарик.
Мультитул для дрібного ремонту.
Стрільба дуже шкодить слуху. Активні беруші вставляєш у вухо.
Все чуєш, однак коли лунає постріл,
звук вимикається.
Їх можна підзаряжати батарейками.
Друзі, дивіться, яка зручна штука.
Спотачку я подумав, що це парасоля.
Але насправді це ось таке сидіння.
Дуже зручний винахід.
До зйомки теми про мисливців, часто гуляючи в німецьких лісах,
я бачив от такі сидіння. Тепер я знаю, що це лабаз.
Я угледів з висоти чотирьох метрів двох вершниць.
Ще тут трапляються бігуни, велосипедисти, любителі прогулянок.
Тож стріляючи, особливо з нарізного карабіна,
мисливець має пересвідчитися, що поблизу немає людей,
і цілитися з високого сидіння так, щоб куля  входила в землю.
Також Ґерд Шпікер наголошує, що на відміну від водіїв у ФРН,
у крові яких допускається до 0,5 проміле алкоголю,
мисливець під час полювання має бути абсолютно тверезий.
Уже після полювання, коли зброя в надійному місці,
можна випити і травити мисливські байки.
Виявилося, що наш герой знає й рибальські анекдоти.
Учора я впіймав рибу. Усі вже втягнули голови,
бо зараз махатиме руками, а він – отакі очі, отакі!
21:00. У Бонні на Рейні починає клювати риба.
Давайте спустимося поближче ось до тих автомобілів
і познайомимось з німецькими рибаками.
Ось так дуже зручно на місці для спуску човнів
під'їжджати автівкою до самого краю води.
Сьогодні рибалять троє друзів: Герберт, Штефан та Ян.
Герберт - найдосвідченіший серед них, рибалка зі стажем 40 років.
Склавши іспит, в управлінні муніципалітету
можна отримати посвідчення рибалки на 5 років.
Воно дає право купувати ліцензії на вилов риби у конкретній водоймі.
Ось я маю такий дозвіл на риболовлю у річці Рейн на 2020-й рік.
Вартість річної ліцензії на вилов у Рейні - 46 євро.
До 300 євро треба викласти за курси, іспит і отримання посвідчення рибалки.
Курси тривають 2,5 місяці. Іспит  письмовий, є і практична частина.
Необхідно правильно відповісти щонайменше на 45 питань з 60.
Треба знати будову риб, типи водойм і вудок, закони і правила риболовлі.
Наприклад, у ФРН заборонено тримати виловлену рибу живою.
Якщо ви виловлену рибу хочете забрати із собою,
треба її оглушити ось так по голові.
Після цього рибу треба вбити, проколовши серце.
Німці вважають такий метод гуманнішим за тримання риби
годинами у відрі або у сачку перед умертвінням.
Якщо контролер виявить живу рибу на березі, штраф - 250 євро.
Можна ловити максимум на дві вудки.
Причому одна вудка - один гачок.
Ловля на живця заборонена.
Сітки, електровудки, вибухівка, нестандартні снасті - поза законом.
Штраф за сітки - 5 тисяч євро. Впіймають повторно - 10 тисяч.
Це вже прирівнюється до  крадіжки, тож можна і за ґрати сісти
У дозволі на вилов чітко вказані розміри і вага по кожному виду риб.
Менших риб треба відпускати. Наприклад, короп має бути не менше 45 см.
Ловити можна обмежену кількість риб на день.
Мені вудку в руки навіть для фото не дають.
Немає посвідчення, тож за законом не маю права ані закидувати вудку, ані витягати улов.
Навіть дітям з 8 до 16 років треба оформлювати спеціальне посвідчення рибалки.
Я можу хіба лишень наживку начепити на гачок.
Це мій вільний час, відновлення, спокій.
Я склав іспит рибалки у 18 років.
Рибалка для мене - це свобода, бути вечорами на воді, на свіжому повітрі, гарний улов.
Я це роблю з восьмирічного віку.
Рейн - жвава судноплавна ріка. Навіть увечері  потік барж не вщухає.
Питаю рибалок, чи не заважає це риболовлі.
Риби до цього звикли, до постійного руху суден.
Це майже не створює проблем.
От якби ця баржа тут зупинилася, це змінило б течію.
Щойно Штефан це сказав, інша баржа стала на якір прямо навпроти.
Рибалка сьогодні не задалася. Загалом, зі слів рибалок, у Рейні живуть 25 різновидів риб.
Однак так було не завжди.
У 1986 році пожежа на хімічному заводі фірми Sandoz
у швейцарському Базелі призвела до скидання у річку
30 тонн пестицидів, ртуті та інших хімікатів. Рейн став червоним.
Загинули сотні тисяч риб, повністю зник лосось.
Тоді ухвалили Програму дій "Рейн", розраховану до 2000 року.
Мільярди вклали в системи очистки стоків. Лосось повернувся в річку вже у 1997-му.
Його вилов заборонений, тож Рейн - це приклад того,
як людина може віддавати свої борги природі.
Пишіть у коментарях, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину,
і я обов'язково про це розповім у наступній серії. Побачимось!